ah non là etc sur devis de vidéos
bonjour aujourd'hui n'est sûr sort du
compte ça fait du milieu j'ai réfléchi à
comment ça se dit [ __ ]
et qu'est ce que c'est que ce soit
content c'est un simulateur de roi yom
et de rois tout court voici donc
l'interface du jeu on a de l'argent on a
un peuple et on a un indice de
satisfaction je suis là je balance comme
ça mais j'en sais rien mais bon c'est à
dire je vais t'aider à diriger son
royaume
mais tu vas devoir faire des choix qui
répondra juste par oui ou non ok ok
notre ville est très petit actuellement
mais elle a carrément le potentiel de
grossir actuellement la seule chose que
tu dois te soucier et de rendre les
citoyens heureux et de faire grossir la
population fait au mieux sur ok my lady
et elle s'en va et c'est parti premiers
habitants qui finalement est un amas de
déchets est un site pour dire aux gens
d'arrêter de m'appeler une slim ball
je me sens mal à cause de sa non non tu
étais à gueule du limon au même il est
dégoûté à l'esav est gage et gros ça va
tu as volé les autres bastions je dis
non à la demande
là j'ai une proposition de business pour
toi et ta petite ville t'intéresser ok
c'est quoi parra je t'apporterai bientôt
des détails
ok maman dis que j'ai besoin de votre
permission pour partir à l'aventuré
allez va mon enfant va à moustoir ouais
je suis pas excité d'explorer je suis
sûre il va se faire buter la mer il va
se plaint des jours et moins 20 des
satisfactions c'est toujours comme ça et
après il ya la démocratie qui arrive je
suis détrôner bref une cour abroge et ça
c est ma quoi voilà ma couronne elle est
parfaite
attachons watch bat khurts quoi ces
conneries automne premier ministre car
suivant il ya un enfant trip puant qui
court dans les rues
est ce qu'on doit la forcer à avoir un
bain et énergique aux avons un savon
tomber dessus
ça me tombe dessus qu'est ce qui s'passe
la démocratie qui vient pour aller aux
tirs le tort de vases deuxième but et
tout - pourquoi parce qu'elle n'est pas
contente qu'on doive la laver mais les
autres sont contents ils se tapent et
l'odeur je dois avoir plus 10 d'un
indice de satisfaction je suis dit que
pouvais-je ont terminé population +0 les
gens sont tristes la ville se rétrécit
ouais mais j'ai encore ma couronne mon
pote hockey deuxième jour donc le mec a
totalement la gueule d'un voleur
d'innocents d'anjou qui te stones
pendant 20 minutes et qui t'ont kull est
dit que les gardiens ont confisqué de
l'ordre qu'il avait trouvé et qu'il
aimerait récupérer
va te faire [ __ ]
voici comment gagner 25 pièces d'or
s'arrache pas de mots ce qui va te faire
[ __ ] non mais il va juste te duels et
humiliés au le coffre asie mais deux
minutes sauf dans nos fussent remember
les souvenirs d'europe jeu léger
l'anneau tout ça j'ai accidentellement
manger quelques personnes devant le
bâtiment et sera au tour je peux juste
payer avec de l'or tu crois que tu peux
en acheter comme ça
merci gamin oberlin je passais par là et
je me suis dit que tu aimerais un petit
peu de magie tu veux essayer
bon ben je sais qu'il tenterait
[Musique]
ces dames c'est le début de la
démocratie à mes excuses je suppose que
le sort s'est transformé en maléfices
c'est pas grave y'a maintenant monde a
droit à l'erreur fait prendre cet homme
fin du jour 2 population -15 toute
satisfaction aux 14 boy même temps ci
avait pas eu un [ __ ] de maléfices la
as-tu déjà vu un coffre aux trésors
faire un salto arrière non ok bah ça
changera pas fan de cet homme à lembach
et son business
une offre pour vous mon ami j'achèterais
un convoi de luxe pour vous à très bon
prix
attention on érige vos yeux ok vadillo
cure c'est une affaire de merde quoi -15
de satisfaction pourquoi moi je voulais
pas gagner encore plus de thunes je
voulais en perdez au contraire gagné de
l'association et tous au final je vais
finir très riche mais très seul comme
actuellement d'ail 3 comble était c'est
elle moi de dire de tous ces gens se
casse encore j'en ai marre il faut
chasser une action malade là demain
allez vas-y au [ __ ] encore de la magie
maintenant les esprits sont apaisés mais
peut-être devrions-nous leur offrir un
peu d'or t'as pas l'impression de
prendre pour un compte et ça permettra
d'éviter qu'il nous rend à l'avenir
hockey bottine de son jury choisi ce
quartier 200 je vais être très seuls les
très pauvres maintenant aller au quai
vas-y d'honneur avec ce que je te dise
je ferai une cérémonie et jose reyes
amont des esprits peut-être que les
esprits en retour ils vont amener des
gens dans le village
voilà tous rient de merde c'est gratuit
haïti veut jouer à pile ou face avec moi
face je te donne un peu d'or bill je
prends l'âme de quelques personnes non
non on dégage au revoir ça dégage est ce
qu'à un moment les gens font l'amour
dans cette ville et ce qu'ils baisent
skis copule là je vois qu'on est à 67
depuis une heure et ça bouge pas [ __ ]
jour 4 complète et population +0 8
personnes qui se bat encore mais vous
attendent pourquoi layar négatif si ce
n'est que les gens sont un peu plus
content preuve cette fuite avoue bages
le pire roi du monde salue mon avis tu
regardais dans mon cristal magique de
vampires allez vas-y tire jus d'espérer
mon gars je vois la mort et la misère
ouais mais tu vois pas la pauvreté de la
tude la pub [ __ ] mais non mais les
gens mais fait l'amour bic et j'étais en
train de demander si j'allais pas ouvrir
une boutique de soupe
vous pensez que c'est le bolide et
j'aurai besoin d'argent vas-y tire façon
je suis plus à ça près met toi bien mais
toi bien cousine +10 gens mais attend
elle fait des soupes ça attire les gens
coincés à bout de grand mère sage
avouant [ __ ] lui ma pire douillet je
passais par là je me disais que vous
aimeriez bien peu de magie tout peut
arriver vous l'essayez vas-y métal et je
me suis dit qu'est deux fois la
troisième voie là oui oh [ __ ] c'est la
remontée darrois allez je remets cette
couronne au peuple parce que je suis
vraiment un roi clément vous prendrez
cet homme qui a mis la couronne sur sa
tête les ouvriers aimerait construire
plus de maisons en ville
ils veulent de l'argent avec lequel ils
pourront construire plus vite mais de
leur avec grand plaisir à l'est est la
mecque et du coup on attend la fin de la
journée il ya des gens qui vont venir du
coup mais pourquoi parce que j'avais
happiness moins 5 et r j'avais happiness
plus de il ya huit mais qui sont quand
même parti qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
pour que les gens restent mais vous êtes
prêts pour qui la jeune écraserait tout
c'est vous dire qu'afin on a capturé des
prisonniers aux jambes bataille est ce
que devrait les apporter ici et les
mettre au travail
we make mais oui mais oui mais quelle
bonne idée déjà si ça fait 8 mais qu'en
plus de la petite ville de merde
ensuite parce qu'on va les exploiter
monde vous connaît pas le smic nous
connaît pas au mont cher j'ai eu la
terrible nouvelle dans le journal
aujourd'hui tu pense que tout ira bien
mais oui je me tue pas mais bien sûr
bien sûr un très bon alors là s'il ya
des gens qui mais pourquoi vous barrez
mais qu'est-ce qui va des marches un
mauvais rebond
voilà l'homme d'affaires de 2 mois 200
pièces d'or et je t'emmène un truc va
zouker si je suis en vacances je dis oui
à tout oh bah ouais les gens sont
contents c'est très bien j'ai plus tu ne
laisses par abstrait bien alors là les
jeunes et partent pas y'a un mec là tu
que j'ai dépensé assez ça lui dépenses
de thunes tous les gens qui viennent au
quai bravo bravo
après sa part des youtuber qui pensent
qu'à l'argent non mais est ce que tu
veux que je vole de l'argent aux riches
et que je te le donne bon bakkoury
champagne je vais voler à tout le monde
et tu m'as pris pour le roi dagobert la
jeune fille
dès l'aube et à
quant à l'envers est-ce que ce caleçon
avec des couches hideuse et à l'envers
non non ça c'est pas moi moi et me dit
ça qu'est ce que je dis prenez cet homme
s'il vous plaît les villageois se
plaignent du bordel qu'il ya dans les
rues et ce que devrait demander aux
travailleurs de la nettoyer allez vas-y
elle me dit pas moins sans moins cinq
ans ça va ça va ça va ça c'est quelqu'un
est venu chez moi et a tout nettoyé tu
va me payer pour ça non dégage yann
fattah cas j'aimerais l'histoire et si
je peux avoir le reste de la journée
aof bouygues vinci met toi bien mais toi
bien plus ressembler à mon père quand il
ya 25 ans ça fait plaisir ça on à 185
personnes c'est incroyable ouais c'est
quoi ça des villageois menace de partir
tant qu'on ne leur aura pas donné un peu
d'argent mais vous êtes mort vous croyez
que moi je vais devant manuel valls et
françois hollande est géré demande de la
thune sinon je pars de paris il me
rionnais mongai me pète aucune on va zy
qu'ils dégagent il était 6 me yassi
péquenots là il met dans des états pas
possibles j'ai faim est ce que je peux
manger des gens j'ai de l'argent donc je
peux te payer contre leur vie tout aussi
tu m'as pris pour des gogos berl hockey
way we put some gars fut du temps le roi
d'argos et pas dagobert le roi blasé
tomba dans une profonde dépression il
répondait de manière aléatoire aux
demandes des habitants tout en n'ayant
rien à [ __ ] vous le voyez maintenant
en train de faire cette voix off
complètement nul
et bien voilà c'est la fin de notre
règne place maintenant à la démocratie
n'hésitez pas à mettre de souza plus si
vous avez aimé le jeu vous pouvez
télécharger il est gratuit par contre
c'est qu en anglais un bon voilà après
ces dernières années c'était un peu
moins votre prof d'anglais de chance
d'avoir un petit niveau a ébranlé
l'union a témoigné de la salle regardé
par des vous vient tchad ou en baisse
[Musique]
ça